you know his rugged good looks from the
fall and the fifty shades series
his new movie is called barb and star go
to vista del mar say it five times fast
i dare you
you will fail it's available on february
12th everywhere you rent movies
give it up for jamie jordan
hello it's nice to meet you hi
nice to meet you yeah i'm i've been
excited about this i
gotta be honest i know everybody knows
you cause 50 shades of fault all those
things
i know you as the huntsman and once upon
a time
[Laughter]
i love i love that so i love that's
going that's
way back i know but i used to love that
show i used to watch it all the time and
i loved it anyway
so fan for a minute um but i see you've
got a beard
um do you prefer a beard or a clean
shaven look
uh no i prefer beard i'm i'm uh
you know like anyone i have insecurities
and
one of my insecurities is my entire face
so i i feel like whenever i can cover
it up as much as i can i i go for it so
if i don't like it um that's amazing
well i actually like a beer i prefer
beards i think they're cooler they look
all manly i'll dig them
um do you have an oil do you use a beard
oil or do you need some because i know
some ladies that can provide you with
some
listen i'm always i'm always up for a
freebie if they want to sense on my way
i'll
be good yeah i don't i feel like
sometimes
i um okay
[Laughter]
will it cover the uh gray that's
starting to come into my no
don't cover the gray oh my gosh
people always do it and i'm like oh the
salt and pepper is so cool
i think it's cool anyway um i love your
accent all right where are you from
is it ireland yeah exactly i'm from
belfast in northern ireland yeah
northern ireland yeah um i love your
accent um well it's
it's singles awareness week um and i
know that you're not single but you have
been single
so did the accent help with the ladies
in america when you were single i feel
like it probably did
you would think so but no i don't think
so i i don't feel like
i ever benefited from it in fact i feel
like i was always trying to lose
my accent um particularly in those early
days in la
and stuff when i used to come over and
try to get work and
nobody understood what i was saying so i
always had to like try to get rid of it
when it came to
you know like i used to go like i i'm
i'm a big you know i'm pretty health
conscious but i also love you know fast
food like most people
um when it's on offer and i um yeah i
used to go to like in a night
all the time and i still go to internet
all the time in la
and i uh i always used to put on an
american accent when i put my order in
because i'd go right i'd go around once
and i'd be like
yeah can i get this and they'd be like
we have no idea what you're saying
i'd be like oh god okay and then i'd
have to like go like oh sorry could i
get like a double double and a and a
fries and whatever and just like change
it and then they'd be like oh yeah sure
and that's why i got by is i was about
to ask you what is your american i love
that it just sounds like you're kind of
a flake it's
like yeah can i get some light
i love that when anybody from any other
country does american like we always
sound like
they're from the valley it's awesome um
i love
i love in and out no offense i'm just a
texas girl so i'm like a whataburger
person at heart you don't know what that
is
but next time when you come in studio
see i see people clapping you know what
i'm talking about
whataburger's good it's in the title um
it's what a burger
people um but anyway when you come here
next time i'm gonna have you try
hopefully yep i'm still here just
waiting for you to subscribe
if you don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever help